good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight Donald Trump ran on the promise
that he would secure our southern border
when he ran in 2016 he ran on other
things to trade Obamacare ending the
Iran deal but it was immigration that
resonated no other candidate was saying
anything like it voters loved it that's
why they yelled build that wall at his
rallies more than two years later we
have less control though over
immigration into this country than we
did the day Trump launched his campaign
entire populations from Latin America
are moving north in February for ''tis
apprehended 76,000 illegal arrivals of
the Mexican border by last month that
number had ballooned to a hundred
thousand they're coming because they
know that they can come our current
system can't stop them
if illegal immigrants show up here with
children they're almost certain to be
released into the United States they
will never be deported close to a
hundred percent of children and families
detained at the border last year are
still here it's a scam before 2013 only
1% of aliens arriving at the US border
sought asylum based on credible fear in
their home countries now more than 10
percent do they know the script even CNN
can't lie about it anymore yesterday to
his credit one of their anchors went to
the border and talked to people trying
to cross illegally into the u.s. watch
this conversation it's the most honest
thing that's run on CNN in a long time
why did he take his kid with him to come
here if it's just a work that was there
Suey who's Davina trabaja Casey Casey
viju and i were talking about he says
that if he comes here with his son then
he's allowed to stay telling them you
bring you kid you can get in if he comes
here with his son then he's allowed to
stay our current political class has
spent years pretending that is not true
in villages across Central America they
know it is true come to America bring
your kids free schools free health care
higher wages they can't kick you out if
you lived in Honduras you'd come here
too we're begging them to come here no
wonder our immigration notice is out of
control they know that we are happy to
give our country away as we are a
lawmakers are allowing this to happen
they can close the loopholes that allow
it in about an hour but they haven't
done that they likely won't do it they
should no interest in the affects this
invasion is having on normal Americans
the suppressed wages the stolen
identities the clogged emergency rooms
and failing public schools the fentanyl
crisis they don't care the Chamber of
Commerce tells us that everything is
fine just yesterday they attacked the
White House for even suggesting we might
have to shut down the border to protect
the country
welcome Olli prices might rise Democrats
being well rejoice in the scale of this
disaster more illegal immigration means
more power for them they're actively for
it everyone running for the Democratic
nomination agrees on this if you could
would you kick the wall down now here
yes like you have a wall absolutely
knock it down offer a home to refugees
that is who we are that's our values
that's part of what we do so instead of
building a wall or closing the border we
should choose compassion instead of
cruelty we welcome refugees and bring
people out of the shadows spending as a
downpayment 5.7 billion on a wall is not
an effective use of tax dollars when we
talk about border security there are
better ways to do it
immigration is not basic
dirty' issue it is an economic and a
humanitarian and a family issue there is
no such thing as an illegal human
there's no such thing as an illegal
human says the sitting united states
senator so no Congress is not going to
fix this our big cities won't help
they're all sanctuaries for illegals now
the courts aren't helping it's not their
job to protect the border anyway it's
the job of the executive branch it
always has been so how are they going to
fix this